- [Forrest] Awesome, thanks very much
for being here late in the afternoon.
By Wednesday, I've been
to this event five times.
It's really tiring both for attendees
and for people that work
here and presenting.
So thanks for being here.
And welcome to our code
talk about Web3 agents.
So today what we're gonna
do is we're gonna facilitate
a technical session.
We're gonna show you some live code,
we'll walk through the code, what it does,
why we made some of the
decisions we did about services
and primitives that we use,
and we'll also demonstrate
and show you how the pieces
fit together, how they work,
and what the value of doing
things this way would be.
A couple things that I
want to call out up front,
you're gonna hear a lot about AgentCore,
which I'm sure you've heard
a lot about this whole week.
So both excited to
share how we're using it
with a Web3 flavor.
So the takeaway from
today is how you can use
some of those primitives from
AgentCore to build an agent
that's capable of
becoming a Web3 assistant.
Then there are of course
ways you can extend that
for your own use cases
and we'll talk about some
of those opportunities.
The other thing is I wanna talk about
what that agent is going to be able to do
and what sort of the run
of show is gonna look like.
So this is sort of our
general agenda for the day.
A code talk, again I mentioned it
walking through live code
with you talking about it
and we'll do some
introductions of the different
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore primitives
as where they introduced,
we introduced them in our code.
But what are the requirements
for this Web3 agent?
So we thought about what some of the,
like the baseline needs someone would have
to make an agent valuable
for a Web3 customer,
a user that's in the Web3
space, the Web3 enthusiast.
First and foremost it
needs to have context
from blockchain, so blockchain data,
but also market, right?
If you're interested in news,
sentiment, prices, et cetera.
So we want an agent that
is able to go get that data
that it needs to act on
the prompts from the user.
Secondly, it needs to have memory,
it needs to be able to
remember user preferences,
be able to recall and search
through previous conversations
and state from previous conversations.
So remembering facts about a
person, what chains do you use?
Maybe what addresses do you have,
even balances and things like that.
So we want our agent to
have memory to be stateful.
And then lastly, we also
want our agent to be able
to trigger or invoke other agents
that specialize in a given task.
So today we'll show you sort
of a reference of an agent
that can sign and broadcast transactions
or get balance for a given
address or wallet on chain.
That's on Ethereum, right?
- [David] Yep.
- [Forrest] Yeah, on Ethereum.
And so I think the last thing
I wanna say is this agent
is not intended to be like a robo-advisor
or to execute trades or trade intent.
So I just want to call that upfront.
Think of it as an assistant,
not something that's
gonna make trades for you.
And then lastly,
I'm going to put a QR
code up on the screen now
so you can actually follow along,
you can go to the repository.
All the code that we're gonna
be using today is in here
as well as a, it's not a Jupyter notebook
but like a markdown file
with all the steps that
we're gonna go through today.
So if you wanted to go
and run this yourself,
dive a little deeper.
We only have 60 minutes
so we can only talk about
everything in so much detail.
You can go ahead and do that.
So with that David, let's
fire it up and switch views.
- [David] All right.
So what we see here,
this is actually the
public GitHub repository
that we are using today.
And I switch to the workshop folder
and here we have basically
the entire outline
of the session, what
we're planning to do today
so that you can actually also look into it
and there's like a technical explanation
for every single step enlisted here.
Now back to Forrest.
- [Forrest] Yeah, absolutely.
So I think the first,
the preliminary setup
that we're gonna have,
the beginning, the first bit of code
that David's gonna walk
through is a baseline agent
that's gonna be capable
of searching the web
and capable of adopting memory.
So creating long-term memory
using AgentCore memory.
We're gonna deploy that agent
using AgentCore runtime.
I think one of the most important things
that I want to call out
for AgentCore runtime,
obviously it's an environment
where you can deploy
and operate your agents
and I think that's very clear.
But one of the things
that I want to call out
about AgentCore runtime
is particularly important
I think for use cases
like this related to Web3
is session isolation.
So when you run an agent
sessions, you invoke an agent
with its session ID, it
creates its own micro VM
with isolated compute memory
and file system for storage.
So if you think about, let's say an agent
that helps users process
transaction history
to generate an opinion for
cryptocurrency taxes for example.
You don't want sessions being
mixed between different users
where they're pushing
really sensitive information
like transaction history,
Xpub, public keys,
addresses, et cetera.
All of those things you want
to make sure are isolated
and kept separated from other users.
And so that's one thing
I wanted to call out
about AgentCore runtime
and something to keep
in the back of your mind
as we we talk about
or we start doing the deployment.
We wanna move to the architecture, David.
And so this is sort of the end state
of where we're gonna get for like
the part that we build with you here.
There are some other components
that it'll interact with there.
I think there's another
architecture diagram later
that we can show you.
But generally speaking
this is where gonna land
at the end of the session today.
Obviously we're using AgentCore runtime,
which I just mentioned
and we're using the Strands Agents SDK,
but you could execute this
sort of the same setup
with any other agent
framework that you prefer.
So we chose strands
but you could choose something else
like lane chain for example.
We're also gonna be utilizing
observability for logging.
We're also gonna be using a browser tool,
the AgentCore browser tool
to get access to some of
that data that we want.
So from things like block explorers.
So David, let's maybe start
with the first round of work.
- [David] Alright, so
we also want to call out
that this session is really
intended to be interactive.
So if you have questions,
if you want to do like a deep
dive into certain things,
please raise,
like don't hesitate, ask us,
there's a lot of content
here for certain things
as Forrest said, like we
will like use like Bedrock,
we will use the memory part.
You probably have seen some of that stuff
already in other like workshops.
We are using it
but we want to actually
also get to the end
for like the Web3 specifics here.
So we will not spend like too much time
on like the Bedrock AgentCore part.
We will not spend too
much time on the memory
how that works, the hooks.
We will call out the
most important things.
But if you feel that you want
to have like certain things a bit like,
or a bit more explanation
on certain things,
please ask us.
Because we do not really
have too much time here.
We are like with-
- [Forrest] Yeah.
- [David] Roughly 50 minutes left.
So, and then also afterwards
if you have questions
we are outside, please do not hesitate,
reach out to us, talk
to us, connect with us
or look into the repository.
Alright, so with having that said,
this particular folder or
like this particular workshop
that I'm showing,
we have like all the
code examples in here.
These particular code examples
are also in the code folder
that I will be using today.
So this is basically the folder
that you're seeing over here
and what we will do is we are using
like a Docker-based approach
so something that is actually
really close to production.
So we are assuming like
okay you have like an agent
that you wanna build,
we are using like a Docker build process,
we are pushing it to ECR,
basically like to contain our repository
and we are actually
fetching it from there.
So you will see this,
and just this is actually
because it is really like
more like closer to production
instead of using like
any of the wrapping tools
or like bootstrapping tools for this.
Alright, also there in our,
if you are following
through on your own machine,
there are a certain set of policies
required in the IM policy for example
for a CLI to deploy these
things, pointing it out
for sure you need like couple of Bedrock
and Bedrock AgentCore requirements
but we have these things
actually listed in the README
or in the workshop file as well.
Alright, so the first module is actually,
now we will now create
like a base Strands Agent
using like with memory support basically.
To do that we have like UV in it.
So UV is like a Python,
like a next generation
Python package manager,
and like the README
or this particular workshop file
explains how you set up everything,
how you're creating it,
you run UV in it, you run UVM,
and then add like boto3,
the Python dependencies Bedrock AgentCore
and boto core.
As you see on the screen here
we have the uv.lock and we have
like already like this file,
basically the code folder
has been initialized
as like a UV project.
So I can now run UV
or like use UV run to run our commands.
That basically means we have
like all the requirements,
like all the dependencies,
the Python dependencies in the folder.
Also what I did is like
I venved it, so I have like
my venv folder here with uv venv
So you could actually
even source it from there.
What I did is,
or what we did is we have like the UV,
UV basically
or in this folder we have
like the base requirements
to run like the scripts later on.
For example the deployment
or the AgentCore grade.
So the boto3, the Python dependencies
are in this folder
and we have like a dedicated
requirements.txt in here.
This particular requirements
txt basically points out
like all the requirements,
all the Python requirements
for our Strands Agent.
And I don't want to go too
deep into these things.
We have like Strands AgentCore, AgentCore,
the core dependencies,
playwright is one of these,
browser support, browser related tools
that we'll have in the,
that we need in the,
that we need in one of the build out steps
for the Strands agent when
we are using the browser
and we will use the boto3 later
to invoke another agent.
So there's some sort of
like an A2A basically
that we are looking here to do as well.
Also what I wanna point out
there is like another stack.
So we have the bigger,
the overarching repository
that we are looking into here,
it's called crypto AI agents.
There's like another cryptographic
like a crypto agent in place
that I already pre deployed.
These requirements, the
sources and all these things,
they are all in the repository.
So it's everything in the repository.
But like what I did in
this particular account,
I already pre deployed the crypto AI agent
because this is a bit more effort
and I'm actually gonna invoke it
or integrate our Strands Agent
with that crypto AI agent later on.
But we will actually talk
about that in more detail
when we are at the last build-out step.
Alright, so the first
agent that we are creating
is basically as I mentioned before,
we have like a couple
of core dependencies.
There is create agent,
there's the memory client
that we are using over here.
Give me one sec.
Yeah.
Just to create the core memory
because like Strands
or like Bedrock AgentCore supports memory
and memory is like a core functionality
if we are building out
of Web3 related agent
because we need to explain
like a couple of things,
we need to tell it like, "Okay,
what are we interested in?
"Is there like a specific coin,
"is there a specific
role that I'm having?"
So we need some sort of
like long-term memory,
and this particular long-term memory
we are setting this up before.
There is a script called
create_Web3_agent_memory.py.
We can run this
and we have a couple of
different memory strategies
defined in here that
are being used later on
just in a-
- [Forrest] I can talk a little more
about the memory strategies.
So when we were designing
this and working on this,
we started researching
how you'd go about building
agent memory from scratch.
So how would you go about doing this
if you were to set this up
yourself without using AgentCore?
It's relatively straightforward
to use open source tooling
to create memory, put raw data somewhere
and give your agent access to that.
And when we started doing
a little bit more research
on how you would actually utilize this
in a practical sense,
we started testing it
with AgentCore memory.
So just a couple of things
about how this works.
One, AgentCore memory
has the short term memory
which is raw data.
So basically as events
get created by your agent,
those get stored as raw data
in a short term data store
for short term memory.
If you enable long-term memory
and you have memory strategies
for things like summarization,
semantic search from previous state,
or user preferences,
there's an asynchronous automatic process
that pulls events from that
raw storage short-term memory
and vector creates
vector embeddings for it
and stores it in a vector
store for long-term memory.
You can configure how long the,
I guess the time to live is for that data.
So how long the data will persist
and I believe that the
timescale for that is a year
that you can extend it to.
Default is seven days.
That's what we're using here.
I think the real value
is in this piece here
that you see on the screen.
So the prebuilt memory
strategies for long-term memory
'cause it cuts down a
lot of the complexity
and the time it takes to build
a vector store based approach
especially for things like semantic search
and summaries of previous
conversations that you have.
And so when we start
demonstrating this agent,
you'll see it remembers some
of the previous conversation
that we've had with it
or I guess that David's had with it.
- [David] Yep, all right
so we have like a memory,
so database basically in place.
The next step and this
again the workshop guide
asks you to create this Web3 agent.memory
and you see like okay
I already have like my file in here
so I actually have
these things copied over
and the next thing that we need to do
is for sure, okay we need
to tell like our entire infrastructure,
okay where do we want to
deploy this AWS account ID,
and oops,
I already have my account set up
that I want to deploy it into.
Alright, there we go.
Now when you're running this on your own,
what you need to do is basically
uv run web agent memory.py
and this will actually
return like memory id.
This memory id is very important.
We will remember and we
will use this later on.
I already did or created
this particular one.
We will see that this,
we will see this memory
id actually later on again
but I have it in an environment variable
now in my terminal right now.
Also to be a bit faster with like
or to quickly go over what like
how we do like the memory integration,
the next thing is that we
have like a memory.py file
which will automatically be
added to the Dockerfile as well.
memory.py is basically
just like a helper module
that we will use for our Strands Agent.
memory.py has like in this class,
this long-term memory hooks provider
that we have defined for our agent here.
This is the constructor,
we're passing like the
memory ID over to it later on
so that we know like which
particular memory store
to talk to.
We have the function with
which we used our context,
we have save conversation,
and then basically we
have to register hook
so that every time like the user,
our Web3 analyst or the Web3 person,
every time we are interacting
with the agent,
that the agent basically is like trig,
these hooks are being triggered
and that we are actually
saving this information
in like a long-term memory.
All right, so this is
basically in the memory.py
again here I have like everything
in like my memory file.
Oops.
The next thing to build
or like build out like base Web3 agent
we have something called the
Strands Agent streaming memory.
We have a file that
or like we have this
particular Strands Agent.
Strands Agent, you might
have seen it already as
or probably have seen it already,
you have participated in another
session here at re:Invent.
If not, we will just quickly
walk over through it.
Using like asyncio for
non-blocking interaction,
we have like import the Strands,
the agent and the tool.
Tool we will use for later
for our tool integration
like of the crypto AI agent stack.
And then we are actually
importing like memory client
from Bedrock AgentCore memory.
And this particular import
that you're seeing here,
this is basically where we
import the long-term memory hooks
from our memory file that
we have previously created.
And besides that, everything is basically
like a standard agent.
We have a hard code user ID
here right now for our demo.
And what we did is like we
have like a little tool,
this is basically just like get version
so that we know like
which particular agent
we are interacting with
in case that something goes
wrong with the deployment.
And then we have the system prompt
which is basically now specifying
the Web3 user requirements.
You want to mention a few things about it?
- [Forrest] Yeah, so
we've created a handful
of different types of agents,
some that are a little more specialized,
some that are more general in nature.
Obviously this one is more general.
But I think that system prompt
is one of the best places
for helping specialize that
agent for a specific task.
So I think I recognize a couple of faces
from the session we had,
I think it was like an hour and a half ago
about blockchain data.
So we had a blockchain data analyst agent.
And so in the system prompt there
we provided a bunch of you
know tips, best practices
and patterns for how blockchain
data is stored and queried.
And again for an assistant,
this is a place where
as you test this agent incrementally
you would add additional
like steering here
for which tools to use
based on which prompts,
what data
like also for memory
you can also kind of
give the agent autonomy
and determining what
should be stored in memory
and what shouldn't be.
So what we have here is relatively simple,
we'll add to it sort of
throughout the session.
But again this is a place
you can customize your agent a lot.
- [David] All right, down here we see
we have like our memory hooks
integrated with and the hooks provider
and we have to the tool
where we are actually just passing
like the get version right now.
And last but not least
for our model we are providing this like
as an environment variable.
We actually will talk
about this in the next step
with the Docker
but we're using clouds on it for this
so that we are actually now like inference
or which model which LLM
we are using for this.
Last but not least there is,
in Strands we have this app entry point
basically the agent invocation
and what we do is we
have like a stream agent,
a stream thing.
So that basically means as we
do not wait for like the LLM
or for the full response to be created,
we are streaming everything back.
You will see this in our client now.
So we thought like okay,
like an interactive like
a streaming client is like
it's a bit more interactive
for a session like that.
Also what you can see here is basically
these are just like a de-
a couple of debug statements.
If you want to get some more
information about tool use,
about the reasoning of the model,
you could actually uncomment this
and then you will actually see like
how the model reasons about certain tools
and returns like these
things in the stream as well.
But this we will not do today
because it would actually be very noisy.
And it's really good for debugging
but not that good for our thing.
So this particular agent
that I have now shown
is living in Strands
Agent streaming memory.py,
we have this exactly over here.
So we are almost done.
So we have like a Strands Agent defined,
we have like a memory set up.
As I mentioned the memory,
I run this before, the memory,
the database creation
takes a couple of minutes
so we have like a memory in place already
and I have like this memory
ID you will see it later on.
Now to build everything,
so we need like Docker for this
and we can actually see like okay,
Docker PS, docker--version.
We see okay we have Docker installed,
there is no specific requirement,
is this just that we are
using a Docker-based build,
so you need to have Docker on your machine
or you need to have
like some remote Docker
or like remote build engine somewhere.
Now let's have a quick look
on how we can integrate and
how we can deploy our agent.
Again we are using Docker
so what is like required for Docker?
Okay, we are or like a container
we require like a Dockerfile.
Here we have our Dockerfile listed.
It's very simple,
in this case we're using
like a Python base image.
We are copying and installing
like the requirements.
These are the requirements that
we defined in the beginning.
So these are basically just
as Strands agent requirements
where we have the browser integration
and where we have the boto3.
Then we also install like
an OpenTelemetry Distro
in this particular Docker image
or in the Docker container.
This is really so that we can separate
like the operational piece
from the duplication.
So that is just what we
are doing it over here.
Then we are setting the AWS region
where we want to deploy it.
We are setting up the inference profile.
This is like the cross
region inference profile
that we are using Cloud Sonnet over here.
How can we see this?
This is now actually like cross region
for the US.
You will see.
So we are deploying our agent in EU
so it's running in Frankfurt.
You will see like the changes in a moment.
And then last but not least,
we have our memory ID
that we are also passing
into the Docker container
and a lot of these things today
are really like just
optimized for the demo.
Like this is basically like
what we are passing the
parameters in that way.
Now if we just have like
a quick look on how this,
what is different in my
Docker file over here
we see instead of like the US east one,
we have EU central,
instead of the US cross region profile,
we use the EU,
and then basically we have
like already the memory
is already in there,
and then for the later agent
we have like a couple of like references
for the other agent
but we will talk about
this in the next step.
All right.
So what is the base requirement
to build like such an Docker
or like such an agent base requirement
is that we have a repository,
I created a repository,
but if you're running this code
you will actually get like
your ECR repository back
and then you basically just
need to log in into this.
And again like if this
is too fast or something
because we need to explain like
how you are actually building
up the infrastructure,
if you have questions
please do not hesitate.
But other, yeah.
- [Participant 1] You said
what's the architecture
for the Docker container?
(indistinct)
- [Forrest] Correct.
The expect, the required
architecture is ARM64,
in like for example if you were
doing this in an environment
where you're using AND,
you can use Docker Buildx
to cross platform build
but the expectation is yeah, ARM64.
- [David] So you see exactly
this is what we are doing here.
We are using the Buildx
because ARM64 is target basically.
No big deal on like a mega like machine.
Like if you're doing this like on an X86,
yeah, you need to have like some sort of
like a cross compile there.
- [Forrest] In fact if you're
building this on CloudShell
you'll run into this issue
because the architecture's different.
- [David] Alright, so now what
I will do is I will make sure
that like I have like the most
recent credentials in here
and then we are triggering
the Buildx basically
and then we are pushing
it up to our repository.
This is basically what is every,
like everything that is
integrated in this command,
Docker Buildx build,
we have like our platform specified
and then we are directly,
we have like our target
repository in here as you see
and then we're pushing it.
Okay with credentials,
Docker is going through.
Okay, there we go.
Perfect.
So now we have like our Strands Agent
and we have pushed it
to the ECR repository.
Now there's also one more like there's
as you know like you
cannot do anything on AWS
without proper IIM policies.
So we have like another step
that is required for the deployment.
There's a great agent runtime role.
This is like the runtime
or the IIM policy required for our,
for the AgentCore Bedrock AgentCore.
Here we have like the
invoke model defined,
we have like the ECR permissions
and all these things.
And if you're running this
you will get this particular
AgentCore execution role.
And in this particular workshop
or like in the file we will
actually like iteratively
add like more permissions so that like
with more features
we are always adding like
additional IIM permission
so that we have like
that we follow the least
privilege policy as well.
- [Forrest] We ave a
least privileged IIM role-
- [David] Yeah.
- [Forrest] In a folder in the repo now.
- [David] Alright, so then
there's also like deploy agent.
Deploy agent is like a small
Python crypto Python helper
that created for this.
This basically is just using
like boto3 Bedrock AgentCore control
and then says like client
create reagent runtime.
This particular client
create agent runtime
creates like a new
Bedrock AgentCore runtime
that we will then use.
And what we do, we are pointing
that particular runtime
to over our ECR repository.
This is our repository so
that that runtime knows
okay we are always pulling
like our containers
from this particular repository
and we are passing like
the IIM policy to it.
This is what we see here, the roleArn
is basically our Web3
AgentCore execution role.
If you run the deployment
you will then see okay,
AgentCore runtime created
successfully runtime ARN
and because I created
it and we will actually
come to this later,
what I will do instead
I will not run create,
I will run like another
script which is actually,
oops, update agent because I like had
like these things pre deployed.
If you have no Bedrock
AgentCore environment,
you just like run the create one.
Otherwise you run update.
Alright, now we are getting back
like the agent runtime ARN
and this particular runtime ARN
we are putting into like an agent runtime
into like an environment variable.
This one is basically,
this is our runtime like
the AgentCore runtime ARN
that we are using.
Now we are using like an
invoke agent async file there.
So this is also like we have
like a small terminal in here,
like a streaming client
that we can now interact
with this particular,
with this Bedrock agent.
This file is called invoke agent async
and this is actually now what we can use
to interact with our agent.
And this particular terminal
or this particular
streaming terminal basically
for our interact with our agent
is basically sourcing
this agent runtime ARN.
So we, this is like how it knows
what particular Strands Agent to talk to.
Then you copy this particular
one also in your file
and then we go
and interact with our
agent for the first time.
So this is again like uv
run invoke agent async,
okay this is like a random session ID
that we are creating every time.
And so how are we doing?
Let's see like if our agent is responding.
All right.
so now as you see
I've like set this things up a bit
like to speed up the process,
it kind of remembers I told
it like my name is David,
so Hi David.
Based on our previous conversation
I told it that I was interested
in some of like the crypto related things.
Okay, it remembers that
and that now it's actually recalling
the previous conversations.
So now it knows,
what does it know in
the Web3 space about me?
Let's see.
It knows something about
Bitcoin and Ethereum,
and now we can actually also tell it
"Oh for future conversations
please also include-"
- [Forrest] Is there like
a preference, Solana?
- [David] Okay.
So this is actually now
how we are building up our preference.
Okay, there we go.
And what we have seen now,
it has already updated
like our portfolio focus
now we like every time we
are interacting with it,
it will also return like
everything from Solana.
- [Participant 2] Sorry,
- [David] Yes.
- [Participant 2] I see
environment you are using,
(indistinct)
is that accurate?
- [David] No, so what you're referring to
is basically this other,
yeah, no.
We will get into this,
like this is the other stack
that you're referring to.
There is a default parameter
like for the polygon RPC
but you can update the RPC endpoint.
But the RPC endpoint is like
then again like just required
if you're doing like a direct interaction
with the blockchain itself,
if you're for example asking
for a specific account like
a balance of an account
or like certain things,
we are like more on a
high level right now,
we are not yet interacting with this.
Because like this RPC endpoint
is really like the other stack,
the other agent that it requires.
- [Participant 2] So for
like the portfolio focus,
like do you have like a single place
where the memory is,
where you have like okay I
have some memory about like
this is like the portfolio focus,
this is the stuff
that I should be including in my output
and then this is user information
over here in this place.
Like should we like be
splitting up our memory
into multiple minute focuses?
Just can you keep it all together
and let the model figure it out?
- [David] Yeah.
- [Participant 2] What are your thoughts?
- [Forrest] So there are options there.
So the built-in strategies,
well and the memory hooks will basically,
will usually use reasoning to determine
what needs to be stored and where
in terms of like from a user ID
and session ID perspective,
the memory is name spaced and encrypted.
So it's also kept separate,
otherwise it would defeat the
purpose of session isolation
at the runtime layer.
But there's also the option
to do custom strategies
that extend the default behavior
of some of these default
strategies that we showed.
And then there you can sort of predefine
what types of insights need to be stored
where it's stored together.
And obviously this is even more
helpful in long-term memory
from a vector embeddings perspective.
So you have either the
more out of the box method
or a more custom method.
- [Participant 2] And
is the custom method,
is it basically just natural language
like tell the whatever agent
is giving the evaluation
of where it needs to go?
- [Forrest] Yes there are ways
to do it in natural language
but then there's also
ways to do it logically
when you set up your memory,
the memory provider and memory hooks.
Yeah, absolutely.
And this stuff is documented
and I can get with you after
and show you the documentation for it.
Any other questions we can answer
while we're at like a
stopping point, yeah.
- [Participant 3] How would
you be able to distinguish
if you have different customers?
- [Forrest] Yeah.
- [Participant 3] Different customers
might have different preferences.
I (indistinct).
The other one might want and so on.
- [Forrest] Precisely, yeah.
- So when David briefly
showed the Dockerfile,
I think it was,
he has defined in there a user id
like in a production agent
where you have many users,
you would have obviously dynamic user IDs,
you might be tying into identity platform.
You have OAuth for
example, you have user IDs.
And then each session that's opened
would first check the user ID
and then that's what you
would name space memory for.
So you would have all of
your user memory separated
and then that would
resolve that issue, right?
So each user has its own preferences,
it has its own conversation history,
list of previous sessions, et cetera.
So great question.
And yeah, for the sake of this demo
we wanted to simplify it,
but in reality in production
you would have everyone
with different user IDs
and that's how you
would resolve that, yes.
- [Participant 4] Can the memory be
queryable like separately?
(indistinct)
- [Forrest] Sorry, could you repeat?
- [Participant 4] Can the memory be
queryable like separately?
(indistinct)
- [Forrest] You know,
that's a good question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I don't want tell you the wrong thing
but I will get you an answer.
If the memory is queryable separately.
I know you can access
it from multiple agents
but I don't know if you can do it
from some other client directly.
Any other questions before we move on
to the sort of the next
version of this agent?
We building some
incremental features on top.
Awesome.
- [David] All right-
- [Forrest] David, one
thing before you jump in,
I also want to sort of,
I wanted to call out to the
sort of like the build process
and the iterative nature of it.
So the build process generally
remains the same, right?
You change code in your agent,
you build a Docker image,
you push it to ECR,
and then you either create a net new
or you update your agent.
So really compatible with
the CICD processes et cetera.
But also AgentCore
runtime works really well
with this sort of pattern
because it supports versioning
and so as you create new versions
of an existing agent by name,
it will point the endpoint for that agent
to the latest version.
But you also have control over this.
So you can start to separate
multiple versions of agents
with different endpoints.
So you can separate environments.
So you can do development staging and prod
each of the different
version of your agent code,
or you can start to diverge
the behavior of those agents
and separate them by endpoints as well.
So you have a lot of control over this.
The default behavior is
handled for you obviously,
which is just directing the agent,
the invocation endpoint
to the latest version.
But you can control that either
via API or from the console.
- [David] Alright, yes.
So now let's talk about the next browser.
- [Forrest] Sorry, the next browser?
- [David] No, about the next iteration.
So what we will do now
is actually use like x,
add like browser use or like
browser access to the agent
because if we want to have like an agent
that is supposed to somehow like query
like current information,
there's always a way,
okay we can go
to like some predefined
rest APIs for example.
There are like plenty
of rest APIs out there
that provide like market information.
But I mean there are
other pages, web pages
that provide a lot of information,
sentiment analysis and all these things
like basically directly for free.
The data is unstructured,
like usually the other APIs,
they're like super structured.
They provide like proper JSON,
that again like is a lot
of work like to integrate.
So we thought like okay
for Web3, let's see,
let's use some browser
related things as well.
Also just to follow the process,
as I mentioned before,
like you always have to
increase IIM permissions.
So what we will do
or what I did is actually for the policy,
there's the script that
actually allows us now
to use like the AgentCore browser feature.
So it adds like all the
permissions required
for the browser access.
And you copy this particular
file to your file system
and then you run it basically.
And every time you run it
you will get like your
AgentCore execution policy
basically updated.
So I did this before
so that we can actually
save a bit of time here.
Now we are looking at the Strands Agent.
Browser use is basically
being added in here.
We have like playwright
and we have like Bedrock
AgentCore tools browser client
that we will see,
and if you look in the console
you will also like see
browser sessions coming up.
Besides that, we have a tool defined now
for our Strands Agent.
This tool is called get
coin data, SQL playwright
and we have like a tool called
get coin data with browser.
This is calling this method
and this method is then
basically where we define,
okay, with browser session
we're passing the region
and all this information into it,
region is being sourced
from environment variable.
And what it basically does is,
okay, we want to use coin
market cap in this case
and we want to just go to coin market cap
and get like the coin specific information
and then basically process it.
Then we basically consume
this data in the LLM
and we analyze it and then
hope that like it makes,
like provides like good
information for us.
And that's basically what we have here.
Now I will exit this particular
and you see I have my Strands
agent memory browser.py,
I have this file in here.
And what we can now do is
like vim, like the Docker.
Oops.
I can do this now with the Dockerfile
because the Dockerfile
includes the entire directory,
like all the files,
and I'm just basically telling
like my process in the Docker
like which particular tool
or which particular Strands
Agent version to call.
That's why I can just type in the browser
and it gets get automatically.
So what I do now is like I
just do lock the Docker Buildx.
So we are basically
building the next version,
now this particular Dockerfile
is using like the
browser-enabled Strands Agent
and we are running the
uv run update agent.
So basically we are
pulling like the latest,
we are telling it to use
the latest Docker version
for our Strands Agent.
- [Forrest] While we wait,
the browser tool that we're using here
is the one that's available in AgentCore.
So it's a built-in tool
that's available through AgentCore.
It's a headless browser that allows you
to automate a lot of
different browser tasks.
Here we're using it to get coin data
instead of using a structured set of APIs.
Because it allows us to get
a broader set of data more easily.
It's also something you
could use pretty readily
for doing some general sentiment analysis
by pulling from news syndication websites
and other things like that,
which we did test when
we were building this.
- [David] Alright, so
this is why I just had
like this tiny little version thing.
So I wanted to see like
what version it is.
In this case it is now the
agent with memory and browser
and okay, let's provide
and we see, provide some market data
for my crypto.
Oops, okay.
- [Forrest] It'll figure it out.
- [David] Yeah, it'll figure it out.
So now it should actually
use the browser figure these,
yeah, use like Solana,
Ethereum and Bitcoin,
create the data
and then provide like some analysis.
Okay, awesome.
Oh wow, it seems like
there is something happened
in Ethereum today.
So we was,
okay now we have like a Web3 agent
that is actually able to
interact with the browser
with unstructured data
and all these things.
Now this is basically on
the data gathering side.
Now to have like a browser
or like an agent that is
really able to interact
with the blockchain itself,
we have to add like a bit more complexity.
To do so.
- [Participant 5] Question.
- [David] Yeah.
- [Forrest] Yeah, sorry, I missed you.
- [Participant 5] Is
there an easy way to see
like all of the tool calls
that exuding or all the browser
interactions (indistinct).
- [Forrest] Yeah, so this-
- [David] Yeah, we could actually enable
the debug flags for this.
- [Forrest] Yeah.
- [Forrest] This would
be exactly these things
that I called, pointed out.
I have not enabled them,
but this is for example up here,
what's up here-
- [Forrest] Right there.
- [Participant 5] Yeah.
- These, these,
they would actually tell you
like the reasoning about like
what tool to use and when to call what,
because I mean this is really important
and like with agents when you
need to really be specific
with the system prompt and do the routing
and tell it exactly what to call.
Because otherwise it
might just get confused
and starts to hallucinate, right?
With like, oh yeah, I have
this information or something.
So it's like having these hooks in here
and I'm calling out this information
that is really helpful for that.
- [Forrest] Yeah.
- [David] All right,
so we have like roughly
15 minutes left.
and alright.
Yeah, so what we have
done now is like our agent
is interacting with like coin,
like can now interact
with like for example any
coin related market data
like crypto related webpage.
The beauty of that is it gets
like all this data points now, right?
It gets a market, the volume,
it gets sentiment and all these things.
It can actually extract everything
from these pages directly
without me having to
collect like or connect
to whatever, like 30-
- [Forrest] 30.
- [David] 30 different rest end points
and do Twitter feeds and all these things.
I mean-
- [Forrest] Yeah.
- [David] All right, now-
- [Forrest] Yeah, so
then the last step here
you only had two at the beginning,
the last step is connect,
allowing this agent to invoke other agents
that specialize in a given task.
And so the task we wanted to show you here
is connecting to an agent
that can actually interact
with the blockchain directly.
And so an agent that can leverage,
the key management service of KMS
to sign a transaction and broadcast it
or just simply make read requests
like RPC requests to chain.
This diagram that you see here
is from actually an architecture
that a colleague of ours built
and we sort of tacked on top of this
for the sake of this workshop.
So we could show multiple
agents working together
to do something
and in this he had some
news source knowledge bases,
a data analyst agent
and then access as well through tool calls
to a crypto price API,
and then lastly a tool call
for accessing the chain directly.
So we're gonna, David's gonna
show you the ladder, right?
Interacting with the chain.
- [David] Yeah, alright.
And you you'll see this particular stack,
this is the other,
this is the CDK
that is actually also included
in this crypto agents with Bedrock.
So you can actually deploy it with CDK
and there is actually also like a,
like a couple of like
blockchain related things
like RPC endpoints
and these are required for this stack now.
And we will actually now integrate
with this particular stack
and then see what we can do with that.
All right.
Again, it's as important,
I mean, I pre deployed it
because that will take a bit too much time
particularly because
of like knowledge basis
and all these things.
And what I did as well
is we actually updated our IIM policies
because we need to have like additional,
we need to have like a Bedrock
invoke agent permission
for this.
And then yes.
All right,
now we are looking at
our Strands Agent again
and how do we actually update
it for like the A2A use
or like how can we now integrate it
with like the other crypto stack
that is fairly straightforward here.
We are using boto3 for that
and we have like our own
tool definition again,
and this is really like
we are just calling,
we are doing like a Bedrock agent
runtime client invoke agent
and we are then having like
agent ID, agent alias ID,
and that basically tells like
our Strands Agent to invoke,
use that tool, that tool
will then actually interact
with our Bedrock agent.
Again, we have like our
tool definition here.
And now it is really crucial
that we are also updating
our system prompt
and do basically like the
proper routing here, right?
So we need to tell it, okay,
so we have like invoke Bedrock agent
and what is this?
Everything that is for
example for wallet operations,
send, check balances,
please reach out to it.
This particular other stack has like
also some data feed gathering.
So we can also use this particular agent
for cryptocurrency price
fetching and all these things.
And we have like a couple
of examples in here.
So for example,
if I want to check my account balance
and we're talking about like
an account that I created
or like an account on
Ethereum, Sepolia or testnet,
then it'll actually invoke this tool.
Besides that, not much has changed
but I removed the browser
because like we are just like
going from tool to tool here
and all right.
This particular file
is located in the A2A.
So to do...
Oops.
So instead of browser, I'm now using A2A
and will now trigger this entire build
and update pipeline again.
And as I mentioned before,
and you have seen that in the Dockerfile,
the agent ID and the agent alias ID,
these are in the Dockerfile already.
So this is pre-configured.
All right, it's updating.
So let's see what it's doing
invoke agent runtime.
Takes a bit till the first response.
I don't even know what
the specific version was,
it's an, okay.
So this other stack now has
like in KMS key associated.
A KMS is like the Amazon
key management system,
and KMS allows us to manage
like private keys as well
or like, it's primarily
for key management.
So private keys, the beauty of KMS is here
that we can actually also
directly integrate it
with like an,
or use KMS to sign EVM transactions,
SECP256K1 for particularly.
So like everything with
this elliptic curve
we can use the, oh-
(indistinct chattering)
- [Forrest] Wouldn't be a live demo
without the service unavailable exception.
- [David] Okay, I think I got-
- [Forrest] Like probably
if you rerun it'll,
- [David] Yeah-
- [Forrest] Chat with it again, it'll-
- [David] But it's
really, it's rotted, okay.
Or something, yeah.
But yeah, we are live, I
mean these things can happen.
But yeah, as I said, oh, let's see.
Oh, okay, now there we go.
So with KMS what we can do
is actually we can now
sign blockchain transaction
and is everybody familiar with like
how like wallets work
on Ethereum for example,
or like public keys?
So it is important like
on like blockchain,
like Ethereum like the
accounts or like wallets,
like these are like
basically identified by
or balances like associated
with like in public address.
And the public address is
basically like a just, yeah,
this is the public key.
Like the public key of like a certain
private and public key pair.
And when we are using like KMS,
we can actually extract it public key
and then we have like a
bit of like calculation,
but basically we can
actually use the public key
from a KMS-based private
to public key pair
for Ethereum for example.
I'm not even sure if this is the right way
to ask for it.
That is okay.
So while we are waiting
for the response here,
otherwise I have to do like another,
okay, this is the wallet address,
and I will actually go in detail
like now what happened in the state like,
but we will first of all check, okay,
what is the,
what balance do we have on our account?
So yeah, it's now interacting
with the other agent
and then basically reaching
out to the RPC endpoint.
Okay, that looks correct.
Oh that's-
(Forrest and David chuckling)
But how do we validate that?
So we're taking this particular address
and we go here
and this is now for
everybody who has never seen,
I mean this is the Sepolia Block Explorer.
And then typing this one in,
and while,
so it seems like someone
funded this particular address
with some Sepolia test these, awesome.
Now how does actually,
how do these things work?
So oops,
if you're interested in this,
like what happens is basically,
in the other, we have
like the crypto AI agent
supervisor stack,
we have a lambda function,
everything is in the index py
and we have a couple of different
functions and methods in here.
And I can really, if
you're interested in this,
I wrote like a few blog posts about like
how you can use KMS for Ethereum,
particularly with different type
of like signature standards,
EIP-155 and 4337 for example,
for like different transaction types.
But like the way how you
would usually do that
or like how you can actually first of all
map like a KMS key or
like a KMS public key
because you do not have
access to the private key.
KMS is really like you
create a private key,
it remains inside the HSM,
it cannot be exported.
You can import a key,
like you can for example use import
like your meta mask key into KMS,
but you cannot export it.
That's basically the idea.
It's a fully managed block,
like a fully managed
key management service
and fully managed means like,
like the backups and everything.
AWS takes care of that.
And the security to permissions,
that's basically what
you would do with IIM.
Now, as I mentioned, like you have to be,
do a little bit of calculation to extract
or like to trans,
yeah, to do the mapping
of like a public key on KMS
to like a public address
on Ethereum for example,
here we have an,
whoops, we have a method,
there's calc Ethereum,
and we are passing like the public key.
This is the bytes, the byte representation
of the public key.
And then if you look into like
how keys are being handled
inside like HSMs,
there's usually something
like ASN, ASN notif
and ASN notion.
So you basically need to decode
some of these things.
And what we have here, we are actually,
the information that we are looking for
is basically the subject private key.
And this is what is happening here.
We have like the subject
ASN key definition
and these things are all
like defined in IEEE.
So certain standards on this.
We are then actually
extracting the public key
and we are doing a bit of like
merging or like calculation.
So we're taking the bytes,
we are actually just taking the first,
yeah, last 40 of this, of the six address.
And then we are,
if actually we can turn
this particular public key
that we calculate into
like a checksum address,
an Ethereum checksum address
is basically identified
for everybody who is not aware of this,
like the upper and the lower case
and the public key,
basically this is like the checksum,
this is actually how you can validate
like if an Ethereum public key,
like I said like if you
wanna send something
you can validate if this
is a valid address or not,
or if something is missing.
And yes, this is
basically now integrating,
providing all the functionality for us.
And this is actually important
when we are doing this get wallet address.
The other client, the other agent
is actually just like instantiating,
like a boto3 client with KMS
and it's basically
downloading the public key.
And the public key is then
like basically recalculated
and this is then turned
into our public key address.
And in the same way that
we are just having like,
in the same way that we
are basically mapping
like in KMS public key on
like an Ethereum wallet
or an on Ethereum,
yeah, like an Ethereum account,
like an e,
like an, you would say
like in Ethereum EOA,
like an externally on the account.
In the same way we can now also
do a bit of like magic for signature.
So we can use KMS to create signatures
for blockchain transactions.
Basically what you would do
is you pre-calculate the,
you set like the Ethereum,
the EVM transaction.
You take the hash value,
you sign this hash basically
with KMS,
and then you decode it into
its different components.
For EVM it would usually be R, S, and V.
So you have like these
three different parameters
that are being validated,
and this is actually also
everything is encapsulated
or everything is written
down in this index.py.
All right, and now what this
basically allows us to do
is like from our agent,
we can actually query our account balance.
We can also go and like check
like the account balance of other accounts
if we want to,
or we can ask it
to send certain funds
from our blockchain wallet
to for example, yeah.
to someone you wanna
send like to his funds to
or something else.
- [Forrest] So I think we're at time now.
We covered a lot of
ground like we wanted to
and we ended up landing on
the other agent functionality
that we had hoped we'd get to.
So really appreciate your time.
If you have questions about anything
that we didn't get questions
on during the session,
we will stick around
right outside the door.
Feel free to come
introduce yourself to us,
ask us any questions that you have
and again, enjoy the
rest of the conference
and have a great rest of your evening.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)